robert spencer despite the best efforts
of president trump and maybe because of
the zero effort of president biden the
palestinian authority still uses many
euphemisms in terms to refer to the
terrorists that they are paying
to kill jews
regularly
will they ever stop the martyr campaign
in the palestinian territories
i would doubt it i don't see why they
have especially now they have no
incentive to stop it because the taylor
force act
forbade the giving of any american
taxpayer money to any entity that
supported terrorism so that was supposed
to end all aid to the palestinian
authority but then the biden
amen they are completely ignoring the
taylor force act and they are saying
falsely that it allows for humanitarian
aid in the first place they don't need
any humanitarian aid they have hundreds
of millions of dollars from
organizations all over the world but
there is no humanitarian aid exception
in the taylor force act and in any case
money is fungible if you give me money
for humanitarian aid i have more money
to spend on on terrorism
it's it's it's
uh a ridiculous dodge to say we're not
funding terrorism when we're giving
money to the palestinian authority and
it's a shame that now the american
taxpayer dollar is indeed going once
again to funding the two jihad
terrorists of the palestinian authority